[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
guys anna welcome back to another
episode of the leia heil pun show we
have done so many episodes now i think
we've done around this could be the 65th
episode so that's 65 weeks over a year
i'm pretty pleased with how it's going
um so it's actually powered by um icon
plus capital the vc firm so check them
out i'm on socials and it is sponsored
by block fi so i actually use block fi
to earn i think right now they have one
of the most competitive interest rates
it's around nine percent on some of your
stable coins um so i'm going to leave a
link in the description for you leave it
in the comment section so if you do want
to sign up i think right now you can
also get around 250 when you sign up and
get amazing competitive interest rates i
use them super happy with the experience
so i'd really recommend them okay so
today um i have a friend joining me on
the show um so i'm super excited um it
is let's see if you can guess okay so
she's an influencer she is a speaker
educator and a content creator it is
miss teen crypto what's up
hey thank you for having me so excited
to be here
yeah it's great to have you so for those
that don't know we actually met we had
the pleasure of finally meeting um in
miami um a few weeks ago so why don't
you tell us why you were down in miami
i was actually down in miami for miami
crypto experience that was really fun
met a ton of really cool people i'm
happy we got to go out we ate some like
really nice pasta it was really cool
yeah yeah yeah
it was good it was good i actually took
um yeah we went to one of my favorite
places in miami um and miami's just
becoming such a great crypto hub it's
unbelievable so yeah it was really good
to meet you and it's amazing that at
such a young age you're not even 20 yet
you're still a teenager i miss teen
crypto you're having all these different
speaking opportunities which is so
exciting so i want to go back a little
bit and understand how you actually you
know decided to get into crypto
yeah so my dad has actually been in the
space for the past five years into
crypto and he used to talk about it all
the time i didn't listen because all i
heard were like numbers finance just
things i didn't understand i didn't
think i could essentially do anything
with it like i couldn't do anything with
stocks that's how i related it
but when i was around 16 he showed me a
transaction and all you had to do was
scan a qr code copy and paste an address
and that's literally it you transact
you're done so i just saw that like you
know that was gonna change the way we
transact i saw none of my friends none
of my family knew what bitcoin was never
mind how easy it is to use
so then i just you know joined twitter a
year and a half later and yeah that's
pretty much it
that's crazy you're so lucky to have a
dad that's been able to just to teach
you all these things um especially at
such a young age it's so amazing but
that's interesting because you mentioned
stocks so i'm assuming stocks is just
overwhelming right like you you couldn't
even go near that
well at 13 no like i i just didn't pay
attention i just didn't think i could do
anything with it like nfts bitcoin and
all this cryptocurrency like that stuff
that you could do things with at any age
so that was what also pulled me in as
well like anyone with an internet
connection can download a wallet and
start spending and transacting
i know that you did a tweet the other
day and you were like bitcoin if you
love freedom you love bitcoin so i'm
really interested to know
what
you know other than like use case and it
all being very fun and zesty as you put
it but like what actually what actually
about crypto um really drives you
because i know that you're you're
spending a lot of your time especially
you know on the weekends going down to
times square and like making all these
different videos it takes a lot of
energy a lot of passion and interest to
actually go out and create content on
something um so for you what is the
driving force
it's essentially being in control of
your value in control of your funds um
one thing i learned from a friend of
mine clint westwood is that your ti your
money essentially is an accumulation of
your time your energy and the amount
like you can't spend like you used to um
i like you know
a burger used to be like 20 cents at
mcdonald's and now you're lucky if it's
on the dollar menu so you can't you
don't have the person you used to get a
dollar wait you used to get a dollar you
just get a burger for 20 cents a
mcdonald's something like that i i was
looking at a menu like an old picture
and it was something around that i don't
quote me on it because there's
definitely something around that um like
i know you used to get like two slices
and a coke for like 50 cents
um in new york and now it's like a
dollar or more it's it's crazy it's
literally nuts so the fact that we could
you know control our value control our
assets with bitcoin and cryptocurrency
and actually have that like peer-to-peer
it reminds me of like you know being in
the cafeteria when i was little trading
like those pokemon and yu-gi-oh cards
just with your friends so that it
reminded me of that
and in school did you ever have any kind
of formal financial education at all
no not at all and that surprised me a
lot because you know getting into like
the real world kind of you know i had a
job for a little while and i just didn't
like even know what a check was
you know i didn't know like how to catch
that how do you start getting a bank
account all that stuff i don't know um i
don't know how to pay taxes um it was
nothing that was taught in school and
yeah the most that i ever saw what was
an investment class that i could have
taken as a senior in high school where
you just followed one stock for each uh
quarter of the year so there's four
quarters you would follow four stocks
and that's it and it's whoever made the
most money would do good in the class
and i just didn't see that i got
something that would help me so i just
didn't take it
that's so crazy i mean i think that's
how wait how old were you when you
offered that
um it was literally last year so 17-18
that's pretty interesting though because
we're not really even we weren't even
offered something like that um oh maybe
we were we could choose to take an
economic class at that age
but actually it's more like 16 to 17 you
can you can take economics but you just
you know you don't choose it because
like you tend to you choose subjects
that you've already studied so that you
could then get a better grade and go on
and on but um but yeah i think that's
such a shame that you know we're not
taught financial literacy in school and
and i have a whole theory as to why that
is um we don't need to get into that if
you if you have any theories you're
welcome to tell me but um
how do you how do your friends then deal
with all of this right so you're
obviously talking to them about bitcoin
talking to him about litecoin um can
they relate to you or do they think that
you're absolutely nuts
well at the beginning i was absolutely
not um right you know walking around
school and being the one that talked
about like this internet stuff like you
know people didn't think i was i people
thought i was out there to say the least
but now a lot of people are actually
coming back around and sending me dm's
like oh you know i'm on open c i have
500 in eath what do i do with it or i
have 500 i want to sign up for coinbase
how what should i buy things like that
so you know people are starting to get
into it they're questioning it more than
they used to at first it was just kind
of something that they rubbed off and it
was just like whatever but now it's
catching a lot of traction a lot of
mainstream media attention a lot of big
events happening especially you know my
friends being in new york they're seeing
things like nft nyc 6 000 plus people
so the curiosity is definitely sparking
yeah i think it's fascinating and i
think
what kind of is is an interesting way to
look at it as well as is your is the
older generation right so at school your
friends are sort of getting it now but
what do your teachers think because i
remember you saying that you actually
did a class or something like you you
sort of run a class about it how did
that go i can't believe they even let
you do that i know
so
you know it was really a kind of a mixed
reaction in my high school which was so
funny i had teachers coming up to me
telling me i shouldn't be doing what i'm
doing bitcoin's a party
yeah they said i shouldn't be involved
in this bitcoin's a ponzi scheme um
recently i had a teacher tell me they're
still worried about the game i'm in
which is crypto um but wait wait wait
wait pause on that put the teacher said
what they called it a game like yeah
they said they were worried about the
game and i was like
oh okay that's fine don't worry
um i i literally just said it's okay
like it's fine um so i just you know
kept on with the conversation and said
goodbye but he it's a nice teacher they
just don't understand yet but there are
other teachers that do so this was uh
one of my teachers in school he's
younger he's around like 27 28 i would
guess or his 30s young 30s but he was
just like curious because one of my
friends asked me in class and was like
yo randy like what's going on with elon
musk and bitcoin because that was when i
first started tweeting about it
and i was just like oh bitcoin is just
peer-to-peer digital currency it's
literally online cash and my teacher
started asking me questions and it
turned into like this whole crypto q a
and it actually happened like
in that class and you know other
teachers have asked me and others and it
just turned into a q a but only a few
that's really amazing i love that um i
can imagine i can imagine doing that in
school
i just i just couldn't i think when i
got up in school i was probably just
like ranting about i don't know like
politics or something like that as i
tend to do as i tend to do now you know
um but you have like a huge interest in
nfts and i do see value in nfcs but i'm
not as big on it as you are so sort of
just tell me more like why why do you
why are you interested in nfts
i think everything's going to be an nft
or at least close to everything um you
know
we're scratching the surface of what
nfcs can be right now which are simple
art um music even that's getting taken
up a few notches right so instead of a
musician just putting out their song as
an nft they're now creating albums and
something that justin blau did uh he's a
very famous music producer making nfcs
on nifty gateway one of his genesis nfts
what he did was if you bought that nft
you got a physical item which was a
sound wave and then you had access to
vip you know section of his concerts for
life so those are like different
utilities you can offer also you can
think of it as proof of authenticity
like my high school diploma that should
have been an nft you could directly see
when it was created and where the nft
has gone you can make sure it's not
transferable or non-burnable so that way
it has to stay on the blockchain and you
can see where it came from like new york
high school sent this image at this time
to miss teen nfts and it's just a lot of
things like that like the d to your
house can be an nft potentially one day
i do agree with you um i certainly think
that um i do think that like everything
is going digital um so it sort of makes
sense for
for
physical items in the real world to have
that digital authentication um i always
say the same example for example like a
rolex watch i understand that that can
actually the same rolex watch can
actually be a different price depending
on
the supply chain where it was you know
where it came from whether it came from
like the uae versus the west i know that
can fluctuate in the price and so having
that history put on the blockchain
totally agree with you um
but do you do you kind of see it as like
any particular any particular blockchain
would do better i know that people are
now starting to experiment well kind of
it's very early but they want to put
nfts on bitcoin um then you have like
the issues with gas fees on ethereum
then there's solana which is obviously
much um much cheaper so do you have a
preference over which blockchains that
you use
well i don't really have a preference
i've been minting on wax for a long time
now since like november last year
i don't know wax wait tell me about wax
because i remember you mentioned it the
other day yeah so wax is actually doing
partnering with amc so if you bought if
you were like an amc stub member like
one of their vip members you were able
to buy an early access ticket to the new
spider-man movie and receive nfts so
that's that's something that's really
awesome um new ways to like there's
going to be like amc loyalty programs so
that way if you're a shareholder i saw
william quigley on uh
cnbc this morning so if you're a amc
shareholder you get an nft that gives
you like more perks at the movie theater
like discounts advanced ticket sales
things like that um so
i preferably use wax just because it's
feasible for gen z um like buying a one
dollar nft on ethereum could be pretty
hard because of the gas fees um never
there's a lot of great projects on
ethereum but the things i can do on wax
are just a lot more like i could do air
drops like if you want my new uh nft
drop that ends today so if you buy both
nfts just for having them in your wallet
i'll give you a free one um that's
something i couldn't do if i was using
ethereum for example just be too
expensive
that makes sense that's really
interesting and how do your
i'm always like going back to this but
like how does how do your friends gen z
kind of take to this especially in
comparison to the older generation
because sometimes people often look at i
don't really agree with this but there's
this idea that bitcoin is the boomer
coin right so it's the coin which made
everybody who's like 30 plus it made
them super rich and now you have this
new generation that want to get into
crypto want to make money um and
there's like a generation divide within
crypto right so what do your friends and
your generation tend to sort of
gravitate towards more
i mean it's kind of equal um you find
out about bitcoin and then you question
like okay this is digital money how does
that work then nfts like what does this
mean um what what is an nft how how does
it play a role in crypto essentially uh
but i think a lot of my friends take to
nfts
because you know we understand the
concept of digital property like if you
didn't take a selfie you weren't there
so like we understand the whole concept
of i took this selfie i was at this
place at this time here's the metadata
on my picture from my phone
and all that stuff so like having that
authentication as an nft you know it
just goes in so seamlessly with our
lives i don't think bitcoin is like you
know a boomer coin or whatever i think
we're so new like bitcoin's a tween
she's only 12. like you know what i mean
it's so nude like this is still new
money um you know all of these exchanges
are new everything happening is so new
and i think bitcoin will always have
that standard of like being the store of
value that digital gold um and things
like that and nfts are going to play a
role in like decentralizing like assets
like deeds to our houses and diplomas
things like that
i think what's interesting about you is
that you've taken a really different
route because when we met you were
saying how you may not go to university
is that still the case
as of right now yeah yeah so i find that
fascinating because um particularly in
america especially in comparison to
england there's more of a focus on the
importance of university and if you
don't go then it's all going to come
crashing down and you're going to be
homeless and it's terrible um i
obviously don't agree with that and i
fully support the idea that you don't
want to go to university so i'd love to
understand more about why you don't want
to go and what you would do instead
honestly um
crypto was just a passion of mine and
it's something that makes me really
happy and i feel like it's it's
something i could pursue forever
um crypto we're so new here that you
know we could all make a difference and
we could all do something really good
for the world um you know going to
college that's something that i guess is
always going to be an option but for me
right now to have this opportunity to be
a part of crypto and be in this
community i just don't think that this
this is a one-time once in a lifetime
opportunity and i'm gonna take it like
my community they've supported me to the
point where like
it just it fuels my fire and i i always
want to do this
yeah i think that's amazing um i don't
necessarily regret going to university
because it was good for the time and
everything um but if i would do it again
if i was if i was in your position i
certainly wouldn't go especially with
everything that you've built right now
um so i think yeah i i think it's going
to be great honestly i'm so excited for
you so thank you
something which i do find i am curious
about then because of course like you
know friends can understand nfts and
they can understand crypto but like in
terms of you
like do you find it difficult because
you know you you're not doing something
normal right like you and i understand
everybody watching we're all sort of on
the same wavelength we also understand
but like it's actually not normal like i
know we have mass adoption but it's not
normal especially saying that you don't
want to go to university um you'd rather
pursue crypto like how do you find that
on like a personal level sort of
navigating through everything
it's it's difficult i'm not gonna lie um
you know
being into crypto is already something
that's so like odd just because like i'm
we're so deep into it like once you get
into crypto you fall down this rabbit
hole and everything you look at is just
not the same like this could be an nft
or i should be paying for crypto here
and you know just relating everything to
it
it's just something that no one else i
know really does and you know they might
like crypto but they're not as involved
and um i honestly think the train of
thought is different
but like we all still get along we're
all still hanging out but
it's it's hard it's not as like you know
easy as it used to be because i'm just
again like a lot of the friends i know
they're all in college they're all like
you know going out on the weekends and
you know doing like focusing on finals
and all this stuff and i'm just here
like you know streaming and having a lot
of fun and like innovating and crypto so
it's like so different
i'm so excited for you i just think that
like yeah forget the finals come down to
miami start building start making money
start you know creating something for
yourself don't have any student debt
it's just going to be really really
great honestly um but i really actually
want to get your thoughts on the
metaverse because i know you're like
like you said you're big on like when
you're big on nfts um but do you have
any thoughts on the metaverse are you
excited for it at all i mean the
metaphors i'm not really sure right now
like my complete thoughts on it it's
this is all like real like new emerging
technology i think the metaverse is
gonna play a role in like a lot of you
know social events um you know like i
think paris hilton if i'm not mistaken
did a performance in the metaverse and a
lot of people were able to attend
whereas like if that was a real life
event a lot of people couldn't attend um
so i think it's definitely gonna play a
role in social events um probably gonna
help bring adoption of cryptocurrency
because again it's a digital world um
i'm not too sure i think this is all
just really really early but it's gonna
it's really gonna change the way we do a
lot of things as well like even meetings
i think a simple meeting could be in the
meta verbs
have you seen the program black mirror
yes i have i've watched the entire thing
it's scary it's too okay great
okay great so for those that don't know
i think it's a british thing i think
right it's british i i think so i think
it's like a uk show but it's on like
netflix
yeah so for those who don't know
basically black mirror is excellent you
have to watch it it's basically like
this dystopian future but it's set
tomorrow so it's so relatable
and they have all these different
scenarios of how technology basically
you know tomorrow's technology not in
like 50 years but tomorrow's technology
creates this really dystopian reality
and so every time i hear about the
metaverse it makes me think about black
mirror because
in reality
it's really just going to be people
sitting on their couches
putting something on their heads and
just clocking out right plucking out
society
and
i don't know how i feel about it
it kind like i like it and i like i like
what you said in terms of paris hilton
and
um i also think okay here's another
thing i also think that um a lot of
people's childhood dreams are going to
come true through the metaverse so like
i've always wanted to try i've always
wanted to teleport okay and fly
teleport and fly i don't know what it is
as a kid
yeah youtube cool so like
i feel that i'll be able to i feel like
the meta bus is gonna be like one big
acid trip where like you just just fly
and transport and i don't know i could
be talking rubbish but that's my only
excitement everything else i'm concerned
about
no i totally feel that like i was in vr
like i have a headset um you know like
i'll wear it for too long because then i
get dizzy but like i was in there for a
little while and i was like in this game
and i was like on a jet pack and i
literally felt like i was flying like it
was it was pretty insane like it's just
like like you see something and like you
feel it in your gut like type of thing
it was it was crazy it was it was crazy
what did you have what headset did you
have
um the quest two oculus questions oh
oculus yeah yeah i i don't know it was a
gift so i just like i started using it
and it's it's crazy it really really
makes you feel like you're there
yeah i know i actually put the i used
the oculus headset for the first time
recently because my friend works like in
the metaverse he's like part of all of
that and so he gave it to me to try and
um it was so cool like the way your
hands the way like you have hands and
like you're gonna click buttons and oh
my god
yeah how exciting i attend vr meetups
all the time um like my friend jerome
and i uh blockchain universe he always
hosts events and there's always like
meetups for like different people but
you put the oculus you put the oculus
headset on and you meet yeah it's called
alt space vr is the app and basically
like there's meetups all the time and
like you could just go in there hang out
with people like you create your avatar
and whatever um you have your hands you
and like i've been to like talk shows
where they have like you know the people
at the like it's like as if you're
looking at the tv but like they're
actually with you like there's the panel
with the people they're all talking and
then there's the audience i could give
reactions like hearts and whatever and
like you could sit in the chair next to
your friend and like be like yo like
this is crazy
oh my god it's gonna be so strange i i
feel like i need to get a headset i'm
gonna get a headset but i'm also just
like i'm being such a boomer about it
like i'm so old-fashioned like i'm crazy
crazy old-fashioned so like
oh my god i've been being such a boomer
about it um
but how long how long until you think
this is all gonna happen you know like
meetings in the metaverse and
how long like what are your thoughts do
you have a timeline on this i think it's
already happening which is like the
scariest part like it's already
happening there's already meetups all
the time in virtual reality this is
something that has been going on for a
long time now so i think
it's not it's not too far away i think
like you know we've already been on zoom
a lot of people are working from home
now so you know to like go the extra
step i feel like zoom is one step and
then the next step is like vr
like even if you don't have a headset
like alt space the app i use you could
go on your laptop and like you know walk
around you just won't have hands oh i
see oh wait so explain so you can
actually do that just on your laptop oh
space yeah like yeah you could just like
walk around like it just it's obviously
just like not 3d and you don't have your
hands but like you could walk around and
like still react with like hearts emojis
you could speak to people
um yeah it's pretty cool
okay this might be like an age gap
between us but did you ever use club
penguin when you were when you were
younger probably not did you mean it i
wanted to use club penguin but like i
literally never got around to it i know
my cousins like they're like four years
older than me they were so deep in the
club penguin oh my god this is what it
reminds me of like this whole thing i
don't know if any of you guys
watching ever and played club penguin
but like this is literally what it
reminds me of like i never played um on
the playstation
or like
xbox or any of that that was like for me
it's like a very like masculine thing
like my brothers did that um but i spent
so much time at club penguin then like i
had a pet and i bought stuff for my pet
and yeah i had like a little igloo house
and like oh my god and i used to like
earn money and things like that and so i
don't know i i do really believe that
it's gonna that it's gonna be um a
legitimate thing but um it does it does
concern me how far it goes because i
think humans have a really um terrible
tendency to take things too far
um you know we've seen that now anyway
um with everything that's going on in
the world right now um so
i don't know i mean another option as
well is the idea that it's going to be
um not just entirely in the meta bus but
it's going to be a kind of seamless
integration between the real world and
the metaverse so it'll be like augmented
reality as well and so we won't so we
won't necessarily completely tap out of
this world it would be
sort of together side by side you do you
know what i mean oh yeah 100 there are
apps out now that you could actually
like attach your like metamask over to
and buy a plot of land that could
represent like times square for example
and put your nfts or just an image there
so if anyone else has that app they
could walk over to your plot and put
their camera up and see your nfts and
see that you own that platform
like that that's something that's
already here
yeah gosh it's so crazy i wonder how do
you know what i'm actually afraid of in
some ways i'm afraid of of becoming of
getting older and becoming that person
that like doesn't understand the new
technology because like what you just
said
no no like what you just said goes right
over my head so like when you come back
to miami you'll have to show me um
i'm afraid of becoming that person that
just no
no it's hard it's hard to keep up it's
hard to you know it's really hard to
keep up with like all the different
things that's happening different apps
different technology um yeah i think
it's difficult to stay on top of all of
it i mean
i don't know for me it's like not like
difficult just because like i'm just
scrolling through twitter all the time
i'm like so immersed in this stuff that
i don't even realize it it's like when i
talk i'm like oh i knew that like it's
so weird it's crazy but like yeah i i
think it's funny how you're talking
about like how you're being such a
boomer about it but like you're like
leading people into digital money and
people i know still don't even have
debit cards there's still people that
are literally writing checks
to pay things oh still that's what i was
going to ask you so have you ever opened
up a bank account then or just no no i
have yeah but you did like i don't
really do anymore but like um i was
getting paid in fiat for a little bit
and i've had to you know
use a bank account for that um and when
i was little like i had a savings
account like that was before my family
and i really found out about
cryptocurrency and its wonders um and i
used to have savings now i have bitcoin
so it's like
i thought you know i saw like my money
was only staying that amount like that
like a 200 that 200 or whatever was
staying 200
and i couldn't do as much with that 200
dollars
so then i was like oh big
that makes sense
and how did your dad get into crypto
i've never asked you that
he was actually you know like scrolling
on facebook one day and found bitcoin
ben's live stream i don't know if you
know who bitcoin ben is um he was he
used to be a truck driver so my dad
caught him like early on when he was in
his truck every morning and he was
talking about like this bitcoin and this
litecoin so my dad thought it was an
actual physical coin and started
googling it and then he was like oh okay
so this is like digital money and he
started getting into it made friends and
then he was talking to me about it and i
was like yeah whatever um
fast forward five six years here i am so
i think it's amazing i think it's so
exciting and then obviously there's the
whole news with facebook and you know
with their metaverse which is obviously
going to be quite centralized um versus
i think like the winklevoss have just um
raised the i think i don't know i could
again pulling this number after now i
think it's like 400 million dollars i
think don't quote me um on building a
decentralized metaverse um so would you
ever be interested in using like a meta
type metaverse which is more centralized
i mean the oculus is made by facebook so
i mean like that's that's who is like i
think the leading vr people like i don't
i haven't heard of another vr company i
mean i haven't looked into it that much
that sells headsets but oculus is
definitely the top right now and that's
made by facebook but i do think that
there's gonna be decentralized versions
and you know
i think you know some people are gonna
want to use that the centralized ones
and that's like cool
but
again it's like all freedom of choice
and like we're like i'm probably gonna
dip into each one and like see what's up
but i obviously prefer like you know if
there's like a decentralized thing i
could probably have more utility on
there then yeah that would be really
cool
i think you and i obviously were having
this conversation and we obviously agree
that all of this is inevitably the
future so
do you ever meet people who are much
older and like how do you start
convincing them just as an example um
like i had like um i didn't break my
knee but i basically injured my knee
earlier this year um and so the guy that
was like fixing my knee i got into a
whole debate with him about like bitcoin
versus gold and like i was going through
it like i was at the hospital going
through it with him like no there's
bitcoins like this and gold is like that
and everything that he said i was like
coming back like fire it was good fun so
like have you ever been in that kind of
situation and what is your sort of go-to
argument which really just um
explains why this is the future
well
it depends on who i'm talking to really
but like if they're if they're going
like you know
if they're just saying like oh i don't
understand digital money i'm gonna be
like well do you use your debit card do
you transact over the onset as it is uh
and they're like yeah so i'm like okay
you're doing that already now here's
bitcoin and this is why bitcoin's
important and i go into like store value
almost it's peer-to-peer no intermediate
like no third parties um it's borderless
any anyone with an internet connection
could transact and they're like oh okay
um you know of course like you know
there are there are people that value
like that just don't want to invest in
crypto they don't believe in it they
believe in like you know their
national currency and like that's cool
that's fine i could just say like you
know would you rather have your dollar
from like 11 years ago when bitcoin was
like six cents or would you rather have
your
the bitcoin from then the one dollar
from then or the one dollar from
now
yeah it's a really good point and i
think yeah i think i think like you know
inflation and showing them um you know
how the purchasing power of these fiat
currencies are just crashing um there's
a really good way to go about it um i
think you know it's interesting when you
when you you know talk about it as like
have your national currency um i won't
make you comment on this don't worry um
you're welcome to if you want to um but
you know like it's interesting because i
think um from my perspective everything
that's going on in the world right now
we tend to see um a lot of nations
really just like screwing over their
citizens um and that's all you know if
for example like
the medical mandates come in in the in
england i for one will feel like um my
country has just screwed me right like
my country just discriminating against
me and hates me and and so as a result
like i don't want to hold their money
like it's even that you know i don't
feel i don't feel patriotic to a certain
currency i don't feel any love for a
certain country i don't feel an edit for
that patriotism of course if you look at
the purchasing power of the pound it's
been crashing inflation is up 4.2
from what they've said so there's many
different things which makes me you know
obviously not want to use it but then on
top of that just using the time like
national currency
it has such like patriot patriotic kind
of tendencies involved in that and i for
one at this point i'm just like i'm no
longer a patriot unfortunately um given
everything that's going on right now in
the world um so
what i love about crypto is how it's
it is apolitical you know like it is it
is
it is it is a political and i think that
bitcoin tends to um
you know be borderless
it's not doesn't belong to a tree there
is no politics involved and i really
enjoy that um and i know el salvador are
doing a lot um when it comes to that
have you ever been to el salvador do you
have any interest um in checking out the
bitcoin city oh i definitely want to
check it out for sure i did there's like
i saw like a lot of pretty parts like a
lot of like i saw like pictures of like
very nice beaches and i was like wow
like you know like it's definitely a
place i want to visit one day i know
there's a lot of bitcoin adoption so it
would just like be cool to like walk
into somewhere like and just know that
like i'm gonna scan the qr code and like
pay with bitcoin like that's just so
exciting to me and like i just like like
you know transacting with crypto it just
like feels extra zesty it feels fun and
like it feels it feels right it feels
right in my heart
yeah so wet so when are you going
uh hopefully in the future i i have no
clue
hopefully you know
hopefully we all moon and i can't i
could
go yeah i think it's amazing i think
it's amazing i think it's interesting
how much hostility el salvador has had
when it comes to from from the us from
the imf um
and did you see that did you see the
tweet um
he did so many um the president he was
sort of saying somebody asked like does
he trade from his does he trade for the
country from his from his laptop and he
said his phone did you see that
no way he took it but that's really
funny
yeah he was like no i trade for my phone
and i don't know i think it's really
interesting i think it's really i think
it's really refreshing to have um like
somebody youthful running a country who
really shares the same mindset as a lot
of us you know um even when it comes to
like taxes and things like that bitcoin
city
zero attacks zero capital gains zero
income zero inheritance yeah just zero
zero zero zero
um that's crazy
i heard i heard that i heard about that
you know it's really interesting and i i
love seeing like pictures of people like
accepting it
transacting with it i'm really impressed
like it all happened really fast and you
know it
it's happening i think people it's going
pretty smooth i haven't heard anything
like people like didn't want to use it i
think it's so easy
who do you think will be next
oh i don't know that's so hard to tell i
just think like it's all gonna like
i feel like it's all gonna be like one
big wave i don't know when i feel it
coming i feel like there's definitely
gonna be more announcements like more
countries using it as legal tender but i
feel like it's just all inevitable you
know like businesses are gonna start
accepting it and you know it's just
gonna be too hard to stop so
you know we might as well make it legal
tender when it gets to that point
it's true i've been talking about this
actually a lot recently about um levels
of regulation and levels of um to what
extent really can bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies be banned and i think
what's interesting is if
governments try to ban it when it first
um
came out when it was first launched
they'd have a great job of doing it
right like i really think they would um
you you know it wasn't that
decentralized at the time given there
weren't that many miners on the network
naturally yeah um and so it'd be easier
to shut down however now i think it's
gonna be harder but i also think we're
still outputting i was tweeting about
this earlier that i think that like the
establishment is still so arrogant like
i don't think they realize the extent to
which bitcoin can literally dismantle it
all and i i think that's so arrogant
towards it
you know so i don't think they realize
and when they realize i think it will be
too late basically that's what i'm
saying like it would have grown and the
network effect would be too strong
yeah i'm not sure about that i think
that you know
this is just all inevitable and i think
that a lot of people you know especially
the higher ups i think they definitely
know about bitcoin but i think they're
just figuring out like you know how can
we how can we use this since it's here
totally so on a personal level then what
are your final goals you know i know you
obviously we spoke about earlier you
don't want to go to university you're
going to just like grow crypto like what
does that mean you know what are your
personal goals
my personal goals is to keep educating
people whether that be on you know a tv
level i was just on fox business on
thursday um with charles payne you've
been on with him as well oh my gosh
twinsies um but yeah like that was
really that was really cool so whether
that be on a tv level doing workshops uh
creating content whatever it is i'm
gonna keep educating people and keep
going on this path on spreading crypto
adoption to gen z educating the masses
and you know helping us all be our own
banks in our own store because this
space is just too good and to not share
all this information it's like holding
all this good information to yourself
it's not doing any good might as well
share that share it share the knowledge
i totally agree with you
totally agree with you i think it's
super exciting so where can people find
you how can they follow you
everyone you can find me on the twitter
instagram tick tock everywhere clubhouse
all at miss teen crypto visit my youtube
channel i'm missing crypto like
subscribe leia was actually on my show a
few weeks back so you can find that
episode and rewatch it all these links
on are on missteencrypto.com you can
check out my nfts from there as well and
my about if you want to check out that
clip from fox business
that's amazing guys go follow miss teen
crypto she's out there educating people
all the time which is so incredible we
totally need it in this space um i want
to thank you so much for coming on it's
always good to speak to you please come
back to miami
so we can hang out and yeah guys i want
to thank you so much for tuning in
thank you
see you later bye
[Music]
[Applause]